[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
return of Gary Goldman his third time on
the show and by far it's my favorite
appearance of his he is one of the best
stand-up comedians to ever do it he's
also one of the best writers in the
world and he's written an incredible
book called Misfit which is available
now I'm currently reading it it is
heartfelt it is insightful and it is
deeply deeply funny it's as funny as his
stand-up which is an incredible
achievement So reading it is kind of
like having a personal Gary Goldman
stand-up show in your living room so
check it out it's incredible honestly
Misfit by Gary Goldman I have a couple
things to plug up top too uh let's see
I'm gonna be at Largo in Los Angeles
this month on Saturday October 14th go
to
largo-la.com for tickets to that I'm
also going to be in Salt Lake City after
that uh Bloomington Indiana those will
all be on petehomes.com hope to see
people out thanks to everybody who came
out in Raleigh Raleigh am I saying that
correctly Raleigh so tour dates are all
at petehomes.com and you guys know I
only do ads for products that I actually
use and actually love and I actually was
just writing actually a lot of actually
actually I was just writing and I was
rocking my latest Pizza pick run don't
walk to this one this app is brought To
Us by our friends at brain FM so I was
sitting down to write to work and how am
I going to cue my brain that it's time
to sink in to settle in and get in that
flow State Well turns out music is a
huge huge part of that and brain FM has
been how I get that into my daily
creative routine for years now I'm so
happy to be partnering with them every
morning I sit at that computer behind me
I throw on these headphones hit focus on
brain FM on the app I hit Focus I hit
creative flow Lo-Fi is my favorite genre
and boom I'm in the pocket and ready to
work create and focus without this
specially designed lyricless flows State
scientifically dialed in music I find it
so much harder to complete tasks I
procrastinate I have a hard time meeting
deadlines but with brain FM I'm
signaling to my brain literally that it
is time to get things done and it works
what is it on the surface brain FM seems
like an app that gives you the perfect
background music for Creative work study
reading meditation relaxation and sleep
and that's true but under the surface it
is so much more than that brain FM's
composers work hard to create amazing
sounding music that doesn't distract and
uses their patented audio technology to
boost your mental States on demand audio
signals get your brain dialed in it's
incredible so give it a try it's a huge
part of my routine has been for years
great way to support your brain and
support the show go to brain.fm weird to
get 30 off one year of brain FM and
start getting more done with less effort
and unlock your best self on demand
experience the difference that the right
music can make in your life brain dot fm
weird support the show support your
noodle also I for years years decades
never washed my hair hate shampoo I hate
looking like a bale of hay that just got
out of the dryer crispy hard to control
horrible looking hair so I just didn't
wash it until cat my hairdresser she was
like Pete this is disgusting you need to
wash your hair yuck I was with her I
know I just didn't know A Better Way
thankfully modern mammals has come to
the rescue it's the only shampoo that's
like a non-shampoo that somehow cleans
your hair so the comb goes right through
it super clean but leaves it perfect
it's not gonna Frizzle it it's not gonna
fry it you're not gonna have to wear a
hat for three days or hope no one takes
your picture you get a perfect hair day
on demand it has structure it still has
some of its natural moisture it doesn't
dry it out and it stays in place and
looks incredible giving your hair that
wave that flow that I am looking for
after a while wash it looks like how my
hair used to look if I wash it with
regular shampoo and waited for five days
but now I can have a perfect hair day
just whenever I want on command so over
40 000 guys have switched to this
instead of traditional shampoo you gotta
see the reviews for this product they're
insane guys don't get this excited about
anything but literally it's blowing
people's minds including mine and once
you use it you are hooked for life I'm
hooked for life I'm never going back I
travel with it I love it it's in every
bathroom you can't go back to regular
shampoo after this and it's a small punk
rock company that I love they're
Grassroots these were just guys that
were fed up with shampoo frying your
hair and set out to actually create new
products to wash your hair with new
shampoo Alternatives specifically for
guys and they have bars if you want the
no plastic no fragrance feel or bottles
it's like a magic gray mud that I love
the feeling and the smell of that gets
your hair perfect every single time six
seconds away to perfect hair no joke I
love it I use it modern mammals.com
weird where weirdos can get a special
combo deal and try both products the bar
and the bottle for 44 bucks the bar by
the way lasts a really really long time
so this is a good good good deal modern
mammals.com weird support your hair
support this show all right everybody
let's get into Gary Gomen he's
incredible get into it it's like
1997. wow I go to the comedy connection
not there anymore
run by a scary man named Joey yeah who
scared he's scary to me I was a
sweetheart I didn't know what club and
he was sometimes nice but that's what
made it kind of oddly familiar with
sometimes he was very sweet and
sometimes it'd be like kind of gruff
yeah because I called too much sure I
did yeah but he was too much but he was
uh I was the same I was the same way but
but I was a little bit further along in
my you were a lot further along I had
yet to do it oh wow and I was going to a
car you were calling even though you had
not done it I was doing the open mic
probably after I saw you though okay
because for real like I know you believe
this why would I make this this is
probably this is your third time on the
show I bet this is the third time I've
told you this on the air but I you know
Billy Burr was on the show uh-huh
murdered sure but I didn't the punchline
of the story I'm sort of ruining I I
wasn't like I can do it watching Bill
not talent wise but just like when I saw
you I was like oh
oh like you can come up with that you
don't have to do that yeah
yeah you'd be hard because dude growing
up in Boston yeah I thought comedy was
like and this guy's over here oh yeah
yeah yeah
and I'm slipping in it I'm slipping it
then oh the chairman of the boardwalks
in he's got a mustache I know it's fake
because he got it down in Austin and I'm
just like that's what comedy was
screaming at the Thanksgiving table yeah
and like um Lenny clack I'm not putting
Lenny clack down I'm just saying that is
what comedy was from what I could tell
if I wanted to make my dad laugh I had
to be like Lenny Clark and I didn't feel
like that yeah and then I saw you that's
interesting there was also this Vibe and
I think it was a remnant of the
the what do you call it the influence of
guys like Barry crimmins Bobcat Stephen
Wright and the what is called The Ding
Ho crew which was this Chinese food
restaurant that and and and Jimmy tingle
that that sort of like with the
Hippocratic Oath first Do no harm theirs
was first be original don't sound like
any of these guys and so that was good
to know and also the fact that everybody
sounded like you just described so
perfectly it was easy to be different
yeah so all I had to do was well I don't
have anything about being arrested for
drunk driving right I don't have
anything about hating my wife and using
a a voice that makes you sound like a a
lunatic so I can dude I can stand out
yes
and that was important and it would
allow you to get more work than than the
person who was just doing a an
impression of somebody who was doing an
impression of somebody from the previous
generation I mean you see that in New
York a lot there were a handful of
templates
right Patrice Gaggle where they where
they use a lot of the similar mannerisms
and Cadence and yeah and it's just Chris
gethard pointed out he said they're a
photocopy of a photocopy yeah of these
you ever been at the table at the cellar
and you're like there's only two guys
here
but here's look let's smell our own
farts let's enjoy it it was a handicap
it was it was I don't know if you can
say that I'm not trying to be cute I'm
saying right it set you back initially
initially initially if you were me Nate
bargatzi you I'm not saying you know I
can be dirty and stuff such as that it
was like going for this sort of other
way yeah and that was yeah sort of it
was strange it was difficult because the
audiences were conditioned to enjoy that
speed and that loudness yeah and those
takes I I still find it if I'm
performing at the Comedy Cellar it often
feels like a road room they're not there
to see me so I'm going on there and
they're assuming that everything I say
is sarcastic and cynical and so it it's
just right it's just very frustrating
yeah a lot of my takes are well I love
this thing you I'm Being Earnest and
they laugh because they think I'm I'm
being sarcastic you're about to say yes
in one way or another what are you gay
you know what I'm saying I don't like
saying that I'm just saying that that's
what they're wearing what was my high
school motto what do you get yeah uh our
our high school yearbook The Motto was
and it sounds much nicer in Latin but
the the motto was what are you gay that
first of all part of me believes you
you're of course you're joking but young
jar to me thinks that a very persuasive
yearbook committee
[Laughter]
it's our catchphrase you wouldn't ask
Arnold not to say what you talking about
Willis don't ask us not to say what are
you gay okay I'm gonna give you real
life example r-l-e
okay it worked I wasn't boy do we love a
good afternoon
[Laughter]
h b d u w l a g a
boy do we love a good acronym I'm a
little foggy because I was just on the
road but here's the example okay I come
out
it's a standard thing I do I'm doing the
helium and all the helium rooms are the
same very well built yeah the front row
is really close yes so I usually oh
they're always snacking on hard pretzels
it seems like or or the equation you're
my only friend you're my only friend I'm
the only one that goes is popcorn the
treat for the movies
she's giving these yeah big bags of feed
yeah just dry sheep feed and did you
turn a knob like hamster food for that
[__] just eating dry crud and I just saw
it because I was on the road I saw the
equalize a three kid I saw it alone I
actually loved it I thought it was great
it's a great franchise trilogy
let's hope it's not a Trilogy because
they better make Anton make a fourth
baby denzie's still got it
denzy's still got it
that that would be a the person who
works in the sub shop I love my denzy I
love denzy I know I love myself my
stories yeah I love my stories I love my
Martini yeah one more day and I love my
denses you know densies
so anyway denzy and Aerosmith
dude you know I'm so kind of like PTSD
from growing up in Boston that I sort of
am dismissive of Aerosmith just on
principle oh yeah no I get it
[Laughter]
immediately I understand no because I
ignored most of the glam metal scene I
ignored rush because they were so
popular in Russia's in glam metal but
they were in that era I ignored them
because they were so popular with kids
who teased and bullied me yes so I said
well I'm not embracing that there's [__]
and I missed out but now I'm really
enjoying it no you gotta Circle back
yeah it's like religion you have to go
back and go like was there something
there yes or was it just grown-ups with
halitosis telling me I'm going to hell
no absolutely yeah it's absolutely right
it was the it was the messenger who was
[__] it up that's right and
everything was good Aerosmith says
Aerosmith is excellent but they have a
lot of baggage because of what you're
saying I'm going to tell you something
you pointed out ramdas on your way in
yeah I'm I'm on Maui on Maui like on
Long Island yeah I'm on Maui for the ROM
dust Retreat this is when he's alive oh
wow and there's an auction where they're
selling ramdas stuff to support his
medical bills and stuff oh wow uh so
there's like a harmonium and you know
what that is it's like a like an
accordion Indian kind of instrument sure
anyway which is kind of perusing it's
the last day who walks in but Stephen
Tyler ah he's just living on Maui you
know they get the ringy I saw Rick Rubin
at this thing too so there are these
like spiritual musicians that's a good
book on creativity the Rick Rubin book
it is yeah it frustrates me a little bit
you know why because it's so right and
it just it shines too bright of a light
on how I'm not pure oh stop it does just
do it for its own sake nothing is get in
there because you like it and I'm going
like I need a closer that everyone will
like oh my gosh
nothing is pure we went into this to
express ourselves but also because the
hours are great but it was more
hours are great can I tell you that's
more to express ourselves the set that I
saw you that changed my life you in the
middle of your set in the middle of your
10 minutes you looked at your watch Gary
gulman in his early 30s maybe late 20s
yeah late 20s probably looks at his wife
and says has the gall I say to camera
one the gall I was enamored you went I'm
uh halfway through my work day
right now
oh my God you said that at a young
Young
me somebody put Mentos in the diet coke
that was me and I was like
wow I don't remember saying that yeah
it's a pretty good it's a kind of cool
thing for a 20 something to say it now
I'd be embarrassed but no it was [__]
incredible okay so where are we Steven
Tyler was there yeah he sang someone was
playing the harmonium and he's saying
I'm trying to get us back to where we
were going it doesn't matter yeah it
doesn't really matter but this is a
free-flowing it's a free strange of
ideas but let's stay on what we were
saying because that set
and watching Nate bargatzi too dude like
I'm not saying we're all the same I
actually I think people are missing the
point if they go those are clean comics
no that's not a point Thank you right no
I understand that you could load their
material into a machine and it would go
I didn't see one [__] you know what I
mean that's not it but that was also
part of the idea everybody's saying [__]
they've already said [__] a million
times I'm not gonna stand out by saying
[__] harder louder yeah or more
frequently that's right yeah but that
really the not swearing was just like an
add-on to the overall goal of just being
unique yeah which is really cool but
believe it or not I watched Nate blowing
up and I'm I'm [__] so I'm not just
saying this you have to say that so
happy for it oh sure and I'm like I
remember when we were at the Boston
comedy club and Nate would get and so
would I now it sounds like I'm
complimenting myself but I'm just saying
like Nate would go up and it would be
sort of like uncomfortable like what
what is this like if anyone thinks I'm
talking [__] Nate would tell you the
same he's just kind of like I'm up there
and my phone's not working I can see the
side a lot like something that gets an
Applause when you get enough of his fans
together you know yeah good comedy
people together but it yeah like 1am on
a Thursday oh yeah at the Boston Comedy
Club Nate bargetsy's going like hey
what's going on with my Empires or
whatever he's saying yeah so it was this
uh what's another way to say a handicap
it was a it was a impediment yeah yeah
yeah I would have called you for that
word but I think Gary I need a synonym
for handicapped but I but I think that
comedy is this weird thing
that I can't think of another
instance where
okay so in baseball you learn on a t
they put the ball on the T and you swing
and in your backyard your father or
mother throws it to you and is very
careful and you have a glove that fits
your hand yeah and then comedy you don't
know what the hell you're doing and they
put you in front of the most hostile
stingy mean yeah tired tired and you're
number 32. yes at best are hoping a
celebrity will show up at worst are
waiting for their best friend to go on
and then they're gonna tune out yeah and
and you have to try and be yourself yeah
which is the the thing that takes the
longest in comedy can I you can kill for
years before you're even yourself for a
for a moment I've been to most any place
but I've never been to me wow have you
heard that song that's some I don't know
what it's from it's really good but it's
true
so you're supposed to go up and be but
the [__] craziest thing is that the
advice let me ask you this does that
trauma because let's name it let's call
it what it was yeah starting in comedy
is lowercase T trauma
but I'm gonna say just to hear what you
say
it was familiar to me going up in front
of drunk Rowdy unpredictable people wow
felt a little like you know I'm at home
with this like you mean I have to turn
around a bad family vacation in a
Winnebago
so like there was a compulsion to do it
to sort of rewrite the past yeah to sort
of
use the skills I had gained in keeping
the peace in my family should I keep the
peace out of like even with the club
managers even I mentioned Joey and all
the people that run ran the clubs I was
like I can I can win the most very
irregular
unpredictable people over by being like
a hey chief like column Chief right
that's interesting I I think in a in a
in a in a similar way and assuming no
laugh I meant you don't go late no I do
relate in a similar way in that I didn't
feel like I had a lifetime of of
experience in
um mastering hostility or chaos but what
I did have was this desire to be paid
attention to why and because I was I was
I wouldn't say I was ignored growing up
but the the pecking order in in my home
was anything that was on television
anyone that was calling on the phone to
my mother yeah and then maybe me yeah
that I read that in my book yeah and my
father only showed up on on Sundays and
and he gave me his undivided attention
and there was nothing I could say or do
that he wasn't mesmerized by but it was
a it was a short amount of time and also
I was covering up this thing with my dad
that I wasn't a good fighter like he was
and so I was being I was being pushed
around teased in school even though I it
turns out he he had me repeat the first
grade which was which is a small T
trauma but but definitely had an effect
on mine what was it why why did he have
you repeat it well and this is sad that
I'm still telling everybody this at 53
years old when I say I was in the top
reading group
I was in the top reading group okay
I was in the top rating group and my
father for sports reasons felt like I
would have an advantage if I repeated
the first grade but he tried to outlier
you yeah yes totally he tried to give me
a January birthday and put me in the
Canadian hockey league
foreign
Malcolm Gladwell is the greatest
journalist in taking cockamamie theories
and ideas and turning them into
beautiful prose none of his ideas holds
up scientifically including the thing
where he says stand-up comedy is really
easy and he could do it tomorrow he said
that yes and that's why I'm going in on
him but his I had him on the show had I
known oh yeah yeah he has no respect for
stand-up comedy you show you footnote
this comment where did he say it I I
forget where it was but it outraged me
and and yeah I I but but here's the
thing I couldn't take Trends and and
ideas and make them so readable like
like he does yeah no I'm still mad he's
super talented but I'm super mad about
it yeah
about him trading stand-up comedy how
how dare you I'll say it Malcolm I love
you but just because we get laughs at 90
seconds why doing a q a it's not the
same come with me no if I can uh the
stress Factory yeah go up at the fat go
up at the Fat Black Pussycat yes on a
Saturday late show after Chappelle oh my
God
Chappelle held the the the uh wait staff
hostage for three and a half hours
breakfast cereal yeah and a hostage
negotiator comes in and says let the
manager and the wait staff go you can
Chappelle doesn't get the lady gets the
he gets a bullhorn from the FBI
Dave you do not have to leave but these
people have children and babysitters yes
that's funny yeah the 2-3 train runs
Express from here to the Bronx unless
you let them go now can I tell you and
all respect to Chappelle he's to come in
and do a very very long set and I used
to say to the manager at the boss
because I was hosting oh wow just when
he let him leave the stage like
to go back up and go Dave Chappelle but
I know like he needs that I would be
waiting you know obviously most of the
time I watched and loved it but you know
15th time you're like the f I used to
take the F train home oh my word turns
into the [__] D and this isn't a time
where old Petey's going well I'll just
take a cab are you [__] nut that's
the whole thing
that if I remember being so broken New
York City that if you if you went in on
the wrong side of a Subway you would
think oh I can't afford the the maybe it
was a dollar 75 at the time to change
sides of the train and go in again I'm
going to have to negotiate with the
person working in that box who made
Oscar the Grouch seem seem uh kind of
loving yeah oh my word yeah I don't know
why Oscar the Grouch was my go-to I I'm
I become Muppet obsessed lately can I
say
what's more New York like yeah that's
who it is yeah the count can I say you
brought a baseball I'm not trying to be
offensive I have family members on the
Spectrum I'm I feel like I might be a
little on the spectrum is everyone who
plays and watches baseball on the
Spectrum it's just a question it's just
a question there's so much
session in the stats and the people in
my family that are in averages yes and
they're each one of them is the Phantom
manager of the team and they'll tell you
like well we haven't he hasn't batted
third since I'm like this is for the
super powers a phenomenal idea that that
that that that our buddy Malcolm
Gladwell would would be all over it
would turn into a
I'm still taking Malcolm on the road
okay so when I was a kid there was
batting average number of home runs and
RBI yeah and you would memorize all
three and you knew everything there was
to know about baseball and so it became
a thing this is I'm adding to your
theory it became a thing where people
obsessed with the averages or and
numbers were really into it and
attracted more and more people on the
Spectrum yes with the with the with the
map look if you hand out a book that you
can fill this up you're printing out an
Excel spreadsheet this is a recreation
so the beer swilling guys and the hot
dog boys are hitting the bricks because
this guy's willing to pay a little bit
more for the ticket and he said like
filling out a scorecard and he's got a
radio because he wants to that's come on
and now there are I'm not exaggerating
16 different categories that have
numbers in them one and this is on the
scoreboard while the guy is going
through is 90 different obsessive
compulsive moves with his batting gloves
and his and his cap right and then yes
and this one is called number of pitches
per at bat can you imagine wanting to
count numbers if that isn't an
opportunity for a a Dustin Hoffman
impression yes
my word well this is where it came from
first of all I just rewatched rain man I
had never watched it it still holds up
yeah because it was Harry Levinson is
something is that the director yeah it
was R and uh so my mom used to cover my
face remember when he walks in on them
having sex my mom would come in my face
because they're swearing and stuff I
watched that movie and I relate hard to
that movie I love that it's great no
it's fantastic it's also can I give that
movie The Ultimate compliment I'm
watching it for the first time I said I
re-watch it really I meant for the first
time okay I didn't know what I wanted to
happen when does that happen
that's interesting when you're like
because you're like is he gonna give him
possession or not and you're saying
they're going like I don't know what
that is the ultimate compliment yeah if
I stop you in the middle of a story and
go Gary I'm gonna be honest with you I
don't know what I want to happen yeah
you've done a great job building the
world for a 90s movie that kind of
subtle death to death yeah to have a
ambivalence perhaps maltivalence I'll
even say meltivalence
but dude that movie was addressing again
family members on the spectrum that
there was a time we used to call them
idiot savants I'm not trying to be funny
it was just like a cruel yeah and
[__] weird time and it took movies
yeah yeah yeah it's sad that's like
idiot understood though yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
we know what you're saying but Savannah
is now a good thing but like that's why
I feel okay in the baseball riff because
these these people that are doing it
yeah yeah are genius yeah you know what
I mean yeah so I'm watching it it was on
a TV where somewhere where Val and I
were eating and they were showing like
the four pitches that had been thrown
and the speed of them and where they
went and I was like this is just for
Vulcans totally like if Vulcans were
real they'd be like take me to your
baseball stadium yeah wait they wouldn't
[__] love it totally yeah there are
yeah there are people who are Baseball
fans who have never picked up a glove or
no interest have no interest in in
playing it it's just looking at the
inside of a clock yeah they just yeah
they they
it's either baseball or the inside of a
clock but I'm gonna stare at one of them
because I need I need something to put
all of this power that's such a
beautiful image the inside of a clock is
there anything better yeah can you
believe we made clocks how badly do you
want to know that it's noon you're gonna
get tired
I keep reminding myself the sun's right
there this guy's gotta know it's noon
sorry I wasn't done with the Riff but I
but I keep reminding myself on the on
the clock idea and there are a million
things like this yeah that if suddenly
everybody lost the recipe for a clock
there is no way I would be able to
tribute to it I would say well there are
a lot of these round things with with uh
sort of teeth but they're not teeth but
they were called teeth and and I forgot
that there were Springs there were
Springs and I don't somehow you get from
that collection of items to it's 1205.
buddy and if you look at it you're like
I would expect more if I didn't know
what the inside of a clock was and you
showed me the inside of a pocket watch
just that you know you're picturing it
perfectly yeah yeah I'd be like well
this keeps a man who doesn't have a
heart alive and they're like no it tells
him when it's time to eat lunch yeah
that's all it does that's all it does
and it is miraculous and it took a man
or a woman or a woman the guy who
takes a stand at the wrong times they're
like that's not being an ally no it
could have been a woman
[Laughter]
that's not what
because it had teeth there is something
particularly masculine about clockmaking
is it because it sounds like [__] making
I don't know no it's because that guy
Cornelius Cornelius I think his name was
on on on Mr Rogers neighborhood in the
Land of Make-Believe didn't he no Daniel
the Tiger lived in a closet no no no
Cornelius built something Daniel Tiger
lived in the clock yeah because he's a
he's a harbinger
harbinger of death Daniel Tiger kills Us
in the end no I didn't realize yeah you
didn't know because he's in the clock oh
he's like so when your time is up it's
all the time it's Fred Rogers with a
very clearly just Fred Rogers voice
going like
you go this isn't so bad one of my
proudest moments was being able to use a
quote from Mr Rogers as the epigraph to
the to the book and then and I'm pretty
sure it's epigraph and not epigram but
that little quote you get to put at the
at the book like a closing quote the
opening the epigraph is usually the
opening and and it's just you write this
whole book and then you get to kind of
cheat by by putting a quote at the
beginning and as long as you footnote
nobody complains buddy when you go from
stand up to book as you just have
the fact that like Academia for example
is just stealing I'm not even saying
this is a bad thing you're just building
on others took them 17 years to find out
that fruit flies go like this and you go
they go like this but did you know that
a bird will and you but you quote him
and you build on that and nobody cares
about ripping off because I wrote a
semi-spiritual book nobody cares if you
go like well that guy says that's a
great book but it's also a great Memoir
I loved
to see your particular odd relationship
with your odd mother the way that I had
we were companions to our to our moms in
different ways we were we were we were
The Golden Boys yeah The Golden Boys of
single mothers yeah yeah yeah and you
know what
I just had a moment with my mom talking
about that I had a little dust up with
my dad and then I called my mom and it
like it reactivates that relationship I
was hoping in an appropriate way but I
like needed my mom yeah it's okay and I
talked to her and she's like it's okay
you know I heard about you and your dad
oh and it's like time travel yeah and
then I said to her because I have given
my mom a lot of grief on this podcast
and to her and just kind of sure same
here been like Mom we should see other
people like stuff like that
you know but um in that relationship it
was very tender and I was like Mom I
really think we we just did what we
needed to do like yeah that's really
nice I can't blame you I understand I
was there yeah I was like a sweet you
know what story I'm gonna load this to
you then I want you to talk all about it
no but my mom always tells the story
that I was like eight years old and she
says she comes home I come home from
school
she goes
um how was your day and she's told the
story a million times and I go it was
good how was your day oh and I just sit
there and I look at and like that's
exactly what my mom so maybe this is me
softening because I'm a parent now but
I'm like
can you blame her if it if if it did get
a little too yeah whatever codependent
or intertwined or whatever what do you
got well I think that it's very
interesting to see how my mom has dealt
with with me writing about her in the in
the book so it's it's I I'm very Lucky
in that my wife is a really good
interpreter of my mom's actions and
Witnesses things and is really
insightful valve's like that too Rosetta
Stone she's like could it be this yes so
my my wife has witnessed things and
she's she's given me a lot of of insight
into my mother and she loves my mother
but she recognizes her her weaknesses
and yeah and they are they are countless
but and they are legion yeah but so the
the book comes out and I bring it over
to her and all along the way and it's
and it's and my wife's my mother-in-law
is is problematic in her own way but
with regards to the book when I told her
I had finished the book and showed her
the book she said oh she's a black woman
so I I she says we are blessed
yeah this is the nicest thing that a
mother could say and I know wait no
regards to the book and in regards to
the book and I know my mother like like
just the work has blessed us yeah
that I have this opportunity and that I
I was able to express myself and that
there's a physical uh
artifact of of my ideas and my life and
and she's a very religious woman I mean
Sade By the way is is not especially
religious but grew up in the black
church and so yeah has a lot of the
ideas and and
anyhow I knew that was the best I was
going to get from a mother figure
because I knew my mother's reaction to
the book would be entirely different and
I and and there's cultural things and
there's age differences but my mother so
we've got we are blessed from Miss Genie
and then we have Barbara Goldman at 90
years old and not a reader and not a
writer and her immediate response to me
handing the book was who's the publisher
[Laughter]
dead
I'm dead there's a there's a certain I
call it autism there's a certain thing
that only maybe other places
yeah where a Jewish person will say the
app I feel like that one's not on my
menu but yeah yeah yeah yeah where a
Jewish person will say the absolute
worst undermining negative cynical
you're so your mom is your mother has
autism and bautism and and my words so
she says who's the publisher then she
starts examining the book clearly
looking for
typos her name oh my God her name or my
mother is scanning for her name how
she's represented she goes to the back
to check the blurbs only reads the names
of the blurbers not what they said about
the book I love in the intro where you
go there's a there's a group of you that
bought this just based on the blurbs a
shame on you
whenever you try to be funny
fingers crossed oh I hope this lands
right thank you no you're a fantastic
writer the book is thank you we're out
of time anyway so Misfit is I don't know
I'm just kidding it's such a weird
feeling have I ever played the game with
you when I sit at the at the Comedy
Cellar with a bunch of comedians at The
Comedians and somebody right but
somebody will say something really funny
and then I'll turn to what I pretend as
the camera and say we'll be right back
one of the best one I don't know if
we've done it oh it's uh Kurt
blanket on his last name but there's
another comedian that I like doing that
with tall Jehovah's Witness no t j w
[Laughter]
Kurt
he married Clint Eastwood's daughter oh
wow I met him at
Dane Cook's Fourth of July party and
when he did the podcast we played out
we'll be right back let me bring it back
to this though and maybe Katie can find
it he did the podcast and I'm pretty
sure his name is Kurt I'm gonna be
embarrassed okay
okay I'm gonna load this back to you but
he was at a July 4th party at Damon
Cook's house that must have been Young
what young people
he no he was always he was older than me
still is interesting he
um Gary's off the tour to orgasm Gary's
off the tour he disappeared I don't know
where he is but I call you and you go I
had a college yeah for those of you that
watch tourism you're like fun Easter egg
yeah yeah yeah yeah but everyone else
what okay I'm gonna give you a story
okay because I want to put it back to
your mom and everything that happened
okay to relate I was on Family Feud and
this actually ties into how Val
interprets my my father and my mother
for me so I'm on Family Feud
celebrity family family with my wife's
family I was like did I say family yeah
there's a moment where I made Steve
Harvey laugh really really really hard
it's like this big moment I was very
proud of it of course we didn't win but
like I was like but we won I I made
Steve like fall down like black church
it was incredible that's incredible it
was a really nice moment that ain't easy
it wasn't easy to make another comedian
laugh and he was real and I loved it and
it was wonderful so I call are you gonna
tell what the joke was sure okay I don't
remember the details exactly but it was
named something that you wouldn't expect
a candle to smell like right yeah yeah
and the woman said
I think she said
um
let's say she said green beans
the answer is good answer good answer
the answer that's what you got to do
yeah the and the number one answer that
they give her is like rotting fish right
so I they are really scraping the bottom
of the battle I think it's because
that they're a little more lenient maybe
yeah yeah but I rightly go on a little
tear going so any food you say any food
you get the number one answer and then I
go what if you just go do you get the
answer and that's what makes Steve
collapse
number one answer oh my God that is fun
so he dies it's a great moment yeah call
home that weekend
after it aired and my dad goes and God
love him this isn't I'm not saying this
with any bile there's nothing nasty here
my dad's like I sure Family Feud yeah
it's a perfect impression sorry on the
TV blaring in the background anyone else
with parents that don't mute the TV my
mother's television I can yep she's
watching TMZ right now blaring blaring I
when I'm on the phone with them in the
car I put it on the minimum volumes
because it's it's just so hard so I can
only kind of hear their voice because
the TV and that's how I did my homework
through high school with Lifestyles of
the Rich and Famous blaring you're
making me want to puke right oh no joke
that nauseates me yeah
um so my dad goes
I'm like yeah well that was fun like I
have to I have to say the things that
was fun right yeah that was good for the
comment yeah and he's like that moment
uh where you uh made the guy laugh
was that programmed oh gosh wow and I go
and I know what he means but I I still
want him to step it out I go programmed
yeah did you talk about it ahead of time
oh my gosh that's he doesn't believe in
you Peter Peter she doesn't believe in
you see that's that's what I take so I
get a little tight because that's what
he's saying that I hear you
unintentionally
subconsciously he doesn't believe in you
that you were that quick and that's
sharp enough and here's what I'd like to
say to my to my family from the stage do
you know how easy this is for me
Goodwill Hunting Good Will Hunting this
is not the debate yeah yeah oh my God
because I'm talented yeah and just
because you tried to convince me
otherwise for the first 53 years of my
life I'm dying oh my gosh you're like
you're my protector you know the part of
your brain that protects you yeah just
became Gary Goldman and he got real I
need it so that's my friend I just hate
seeing somebody else go through what was
done to me yeah and so I yeah I've
become [__] Holden Caufield over here
well you just caught me you stopped me
from running off the cliff in the Rye no
it's because these [__] people had no
business
raising kids and they weren't that my
mother said something recently that
everything became so clear like this
like this Grail of Rosetta Stone of of
how I became who I am we went to see my
my nephew had a child we went to see the
baby and so it's my mother's great
grandchild and I said how about that I
said something and I I put together
something because she's always impressed
by a little bit of a little bit of
sentimentality so I said so I know my
audience so I said how about that four
generations whatever horseshit I was I
was peddling with her because I I like
to please her and I am relating hard to
them and she said yeah I'm not a baby
person
your mom said that yeah and and I said
uh to myself oh you mean a mother
I'm dying yeah I'm not a baby person to
her baby yeah to her baby I will say Val
so do I say the Hade yeah but it's
s-a-d-e so I always have anxiety right
am I like is it yeah no but but
seriously
and when you use Siri you have to go
call sad call said yes yeah who do I
have in my phone like that uh it doesn't
matter who cares oh uh my friend Kate
Kate mallor it's Kate Maller but you
have to say mallor anyways stupid
um but you know I hear all that anger
and I share in that and that was partly
my experience but then Val Like Scarlett
Johansson and the Hulk
you know like I hold on my hand and she
goes Sun's getting real no yeah you know
she kind of calms me now and goes
isn't it possible and I'm gonna ask you
too that that is
how he's trying to say I saw that and I
liked it she's like put the subtitles on
and just own that that's as close as
we're gonna get oh two I saw it and I
liked it we want we to I I can make
myself cry doing my an impression of my
father and just be like I know we've
always you know I don't know if we've
ever had a close conversation like you
know just like like a fantasy but like
he goes was that programmed can't we
instead of getting upset I'm just saying
for our own good
step out and say is it possible
that that's him saying I saw it and I
liked it that's what Val says she goes I
saw it and I liked it like as an
apologist she's a Mr Holmes apologist
that's how I'm
no I'm not having it that's that says
that says that says more about Val than
it says about your dad that Val is a
peacekeeper and loves you and loves your
dad and and
Peacekeeper yeah yeah that that's a
tricky one for us because I'm a
peacekeeper Val's a peacekeeper yeah and
then like and I'm assuming you were a
peacekeeper no I had a middle brother
who was a peacekeeper I was 10 and 15
years younger than my brother so I was
just this kind of kind of weird remnant
of my parents marriage that dissolved
when I was one and a half so wow yeah
heavy pretty heavy yeah yeah yeah but
you still have that when you were
talking about with your mom
and you want to say something the role
it feels almost like a little politician
I talked to my brother uh after that
little desktop with me what's his name
John okay which is my dad's name John
John Holmes I know you want the family
joke in our family we call him shorty
and to say something kind and nice about
my parents they don't take anything
seriously they love jokes you know what
I mean I like that we have a family joke
right right right like when I hang out
with families we have our stuff but when
I hang up one thing we're not we're not
stiff you know what I mean nobody's
being a Steph and there's a lot of
like death before wow that's blending in
or [__] they're they're out there
Razzle dazzling in their own way I got
stoned recently and had like a nice
moment I was like oh my God this is what
this plant is for where I was like
I was like I was visiting home and I was
like they're one of a kind but I I had
it in the good way instead of like the
angry like nobody's like my parents you
don't understand my parents I was like
oh my God nobody's like them right and I
had real I accessed a room that is
usually mired by the the from the ground
up seaweed of of what I wish it was but
I got past it that's a great attitude
because they are a gift to somebody like
us or David Sedaris his family is is
just that's what Val says she is that
what shade says she's like that's the
Goldman Factory yeah I mean my my wife
has really interesting takes on my
family because she's also seeing them as
an outsider not just of my family but as
a as a black person yeah and somebody
who didn't grow up around around a
family of Jews of our age yeah and
backgrounds so so she's she's sort of a
an anthropologist and that was that part
of the appeal because I was looking for
somebody different too the thought of
dating someone from Boston is Sade from
Boston no she's from Trenton New Jersey
yeah she went to the same High School my
dad went to but 60 years apart literally
whoa but she's
you didn't want to reenact the pattern
you were looking for a new not just a
new record but a different record store
right but completely let's move away the
main thing in that she that's not that's
not code for Black by the way right but
I'm not saying you went to the black
record I'm saying you want it different
from what the main way she differs from
my family is that my family are the
simpletons and Sade is an intellectual
of the of the highest order I mean she's
a she's a Renaissance okay I remember
yeah she she reads in in physics and
Science and and feminist studies and she
went to the Tisch school at NYU for for
theater and writing and so she's she's
really special so it's great to have
this brain yeah watching your family
yeah what are they do would you mind
sharing any of her takes something that
might help people I had an argument with
my mother because somebody put on a
video of me on a on a on a on a talk
show I think it was the Tamron Hall and
at the time I had long hair and a goatee
and my mother said oh you look evil and
and immediately I went to to Defcon one
and I said how can you say that about
your about yourself a lot of people are
confused about the Defcon ratings
because of of Kanye West saying that he
was at deathcon first of all it's Defcon
he was at Defcon 3 on the Jews and it
turns out Defcon 3 is not that severe
Defcon 1 is really that's nuclear war
but but Defcon deathcon 3 on the Jews we
still have time to get our Affairs
it's like a siren yeah you have time
yeah you have time I think deathcon 3
was was pretty much the Cold War era we
were always at around three or three and
a half four uh but I mean this is just a
person who saw War Games six times in
the in the theater
I don't know which bothered me more the
anti-Semitism or the the not getting the
worst it's hard to say yes it's hard to
say yeah and and then so we had an
argument over that and I said you know
how hurtful that is and why is
everything about my appearance like I am
an extension of you and and Sade said
you're arguing and not in front of my
mother but later after things calm down
she said you're arguing with her like
she's an equal and she is and she said I
don't mean this in a in a pejorative
manner she's a simple woman yeah she
knows good bad like dislike pretty
ugly you're trying to put it on yum and
you are are bringing in 30 years of of
therapy and and jungian psychology and
Camu and and all the other things you've
read and all she knows is that she
didn't like your hair and she found it
revolting
and you can I call Sade when I need this
oh my gosh because you know how many
times I've said this week
I just resent sometimes not sometimes
often I was on an airplane I talked with
the woman the whole flight and it was a
great chap I enjoyed the chat but they
like a lot of people were going like you
know the things you leave unsaid with
family you'll regret so you should do it
yeah they were like sit knee to knee
look eye to eye and say this this and
this this made me feel this way and I
hear now Sade's voice going like what do
you I say you might as well be telling
me to speak Portuguese yes to a tennis
ball yeah that's not putting down the
tennis ball and I'm not degrading the
Portuguese language
my therapist said and and that doesn't
make me a coward it doesn't make me not
doing the work and you know what I said
I was like you know what I can handle
[__] regret you know what I can't
handle I can't handle regret you know
what I can't handle is that yeah you
[__] you're talking to me like you're
saying you know what I say it's not
people you you're picturing a person
you're picturing like a thing it does
doesn't work that way sometimes you like
you like in your situation yeah you're
speaking Portuguese yeah it's a
different things and that doesn't mean
you're not brave and honest and exactly
and I crave closeness with the with my
family but that's not the way to do it
and that and that's not the way for
everybody so I do want to say let's stop
assuming that that's a safe Endeavor for
everybody that is such a great insight
and I and I I love that yeah I can live
with the regrets but that's what valve's
therapist says she goes regrets
manageable yeah and my therapist said
something similar he said about my
entire family they're not taking any new
information that is great and I didn't
know Ray Romano was seeing people oh
therapeutically Alan lefkowitz is his
name and it and there are a number there
are a number of friends that we have
that that see him okay
they've been to Bobby Kelly going in and
out or or Joe list and that's a warm
couch after yeah it's a warm couch and
Bobby he's so funny and he would say uh
if he'd come in after me so you leave
anything for me
but he sees this yeah yeah I so the
conversation I had with my brother that
I wanted to know you said I know what to
say
you know to your mother she likes
sentimentality yeah and I'm saying this
out of a beautiful like this is me in my
because under all the anger is the
sadness right it's the colorful candy
shell on the sadness Eminem right under
it is a little boy me still wanting
closeness wanting connection wanting
good for them wanting good for the
family so there's still this like
desire to connect
boy I was hoping I was going to remember
what I was trying to say with your
brother John oh yeah so I call him
what did my brother say though we're
talking about
[__] no this almost never happens
that's okay it is okay it'll come back
to us we'll Circle back around can I say
yeah when you said do you have any idea
how [__] easy this is for me oh wow I
got the chills oh really good one
hunting yeah it just keeps giving to us
doesn't it it just keeps getting yeah
Sade and I were over at your house and
we watched it together and it's one of
my favorite martians yeah do you
remember yeah I can't get enough and
forgive me everybody but I'm gonna and I
don't think I've ever done a better TV
set than what I did on the Pete Holm
show that I watched that now and usually
we cringe and I watch it now and I think
oh that's what Joy looks like yeah yeah
Comfort and being embraced that was that
was a great feeling that was a special
thing too because the petalum show was
such a
tree house yeah like climbing up into a
treehouse totally and there were Rolling
Stones and Mad Magazines yeah you know
what I mean and there was an old
Nintendo yeah we added electric running
on a long orange extension cord and it
was just safe and we were going like
let's make the comic safe and you came
out and you're [__] one of the best
that's ever done it
living or dead living or dead I told you
to say living or dead at the end of
the end whenever you're living when you
say I'm the grade imagine if I wrote it
out can you imagine I can I'm gonna toss
this Matt Damon at you and I'm almost
done everybody knows I say this a lot
but the Bourne trilogy is about trying
to break family trauma break bad
patterns I'm going to say one point born
ultimatum the best one okay he's who is
he trying to meet at Waterloo Station
he's trying to meet a reporter he wants
witness he wants someone to hear his
story he was inducted through
waterboarding into a system that he did
not want to join wow can you commit to
this program sounds like my dad doesn't
it can you commit to this was that
programmed
wow and he goes I can't they make him in
that's that's your genes that's your
upbringing that's your school that's
everything they're not even doing it
maliciously that's just what they think
we're gonna train you to be a killer for
your safety right then he's had enough
yeah he meets Marie who I actually think
is the mom his girlfriend is the mom
okay she dies so the mom is taken and
then uh Pamela Landy who's the woman on
the inside that helps him come in that's
his wife that's his shade interest
that's the she's smart she understands
the system yeah so he goes to Waterloo
to meet a reporter so the reporter will
write a story about what's happening
that's what we're looking for with
therapists with friends with with
relationships can you bear witness to
what happened because if we can quote
Fred Rogers if it's mentionable it's
manageable yes let's talk about it wow
Todd Glass said that to me again last
night don't mention other podcasts I'm
sorry about that he doesn't he doesn't
cast anymore so I think it's safe but
I'm also again I'm also getting a lot of
homers The Odyssey vibe in in the
telling the tale and the and the being
kind of forced into going on an odyssey
and yeah yeah and but also the coming
back with the Elixir and wanting
everybody to to know about it with the
hero's journey yeah the hero's journey
you bring it back to the Village it's
not surprising it's it's a jungian right
it is it absolutely is in fact falling
upward which I'm looking at it's on the
bookshelf there by Richard Rohr is
looking at the Odyssey oh through a
spiritual lens and being like that's
what we all have to do can I take a
break to use the restroom I'm really
sorry sweat it out here
um sweat it out no there's a we'll go to
the mid-rolls and you go uh make a
mid-roll
okay thank you
I am so excited about this latest Pizza
pick which is first person a mushroom
based supplement that helps us naturally
produce more oxytocin this is a product
that has literally changed both my and
Val's life giving us more oxytocin also
known as the feel good hormone from our
friends at first person what is it it's
called Golden hour using Precision
targeted supplements with functional
mushrooms that aim to stimulate the
body's natural production of specific
neurotransmitters that trigger
activities like energy mood and sleep
that's a fancy way of saying here's an
all-natural supplement that is going to
help your body produce more oxytocin
golden hour helps me tune into a sense
of Joy connection and relaxed presence I
noticed the difference the first time I
took it within 15 minutes it's
incredible and that effect has only
Built over time the more I use it it
helps support your body's natural
production of oxytocin to mitigate
stress boost the Mind Body Connection
and it may even help promote long-term
cognitive health so we're always talking
about oxytocin I mean it's huge the
feel-good hormone how do you get it
turns out our friends are here to help
but that's not all I love golden hour so
much I take all three of first person's
family of supplements and I'm so glad I
do these are meant to be stacked they
work so well together but if you're
going to try one I would start with
golden hour they are so incredible I
take Sunbeam for the dopamine I take
golden hour for the oxytocin so I feel
joyful and motivated so I take them at
the same time and of course I take
Moonlight before bed for the perfect
night of sleep it's 100 grain free
organic mushrooms as well as highly
curated blend of neurosuticals first
person is a game changer it's an
incredible company I'm so glad to be
working with them so start improving
your brain health and cognition with
first person you can get 20 off your
first order by going to get
firstperson.com and use promo code weird
let's get first person.com and use promo
code weird these statements have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration these products are not
intended to be diagnosed treat secure or
prevent any disease but if you've been
listening to we made it weird Val and I
both have been shouting their praise
absolutely no going back give it a try
getfirstperson.com and use promo code
weird we're also brought To Us by our
friends at next Evo next Evo is
incredible especially as we're shifting
from the laid back lazy summer days into
these hectic fall days especially if you
have little kids going to school there's
a lot of stress going around and if I
don't take care of my body and if I
don't rest completely I wake up looking
like a Shipwrecked Captain Jack Sparrow
it's a bad situation so I take next Evo
CBD I love their stress gummies which
have ashwagandha to help you calm down
and the CBD gets into your system so
much better they have something called
smart sword technology which makes sure
that the CBD is actually getting into
your body which is huge when I talk to
people about CBD they're often a little
hesitant because they don't feel it and
they don't know how to dial in the dose
correctly well next Evo is taking care
of both of that you feel it within 10
minutes and they have it figured out the
absorption problem has been solved by
next Evo what you take is what you're
going to get so you can dial it in just
right and find out the perfect dose for
you I love their stress CBD complex
combining the premium CBD with the
ashwagandha to soothe away stress and
stay calm as you get back into these
fall routines so get more Z's and more
Zen in your life they also have the
Sleep support complex which is an
incredible part of a sleep routine so
get more Z's and more Zen in your life
upgrade to better natural solutions from
next Evo Naturals go to next Evo and use
promo code weird for 25 off that's 25
off at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com and use promo code
queer all right everybody let's get back
to Gary
ask you about the dynamic of the book
with your family
um oh yeah
because we only got who published it
right
there are things that I'm sure they'll
be embarrassed by or think well that's
not what happened yeah
um or that the or with my mother she'll
say that
she was embarrassed that I talked about
her stealing greeting cards from the
Hallmark store she worked at and so she
called me about that and it's just
how is that part of the dread because
I'm shaking of it coming out the book
was that oh I'm gonna hear from my
family and they're gonna like they do it
every comedy show well that wasn't true
was it is that how that happened and
second guessing and undermining and I
worked out this thing in my head because
I've thought about it and I wonder what
you think about this and
to anything they say if they really get
down on me I will say I could have gone
harder
yeah it could have been worse just be
grateful you know the end Lamont I was
easy on you the end Lamont quote which
is you should have been nicer to me yeah
if people don't like how you wrote about
them they should have been kind of yeah
yeah I forgot about that oh my gosh
everyone who writes a book needs that oh
that's really helpful yeah you thought
about that when you were
well dude I realized that I wrote the
book trying to be my own reporter at
Waterloo Station like I was like I was
like I'm gonna put it in black and white
yes and actually had a nice call with my
folks
I didn't go that hard
but there was a nice moment where I felt
seen it was very brief it was on the
call they had just read it
but I also think there was some stuff
somehow it got back to me that it was
like
I think somebody in my fam I'm still too
scared to be specific but somebody was
like uh Peter's a drug addict or
something because I talk about taking
mushrooms right right
and I'm like that is when we were kids
we would have thought yeah is a drug
addict
you're right but this is Sade
yeah
he's a stoner yeah and a burnout even
though the book goes to Great Lengths to
being like
this was weird for me too and this is
what it meant to me and all this stuff
and when they never understanding faded
away very quickly that region of the
country and our families never got
honest yeah we would they referred to as
artsy Fati and one of the hottest things
one of the hardest things to do adult
yeah as an adult
performing and writing was to see this
as art and as an artist and that these
sentences were in their way poetic and
and that's a tough transition to make
from where we came from and it and it
makes me admire Damon and Affleck even
even more yeah because they they were
able to maintain this street cred but
also they they tell stories of being
really into the theater when they were
in in high school even and and it must
have been that their their parents being
it being from Cambridge and
understanding artists and and creativity
because we just didn't we didn't have
that and then the artists would
denigrate and they were going to be
broke and and the Perpetual students and
the staff and artists and it just it it
makes me want to take a flame throw out
of this place
yeah that's a great New England movie
Man Scent of a Woman gets me so pumped
up sometimes if I was half the man I
used I take a five
and Harry [__] you too and it cuts to
them in the crowd
there's an insert of them listening
little Phil Hoffman yeah
Philip Phil Hoffman even as a child was
out acting everyone around him including
Al Pacino yeah yeah I know right I know
how good is he in that movie
heartbreaking yeah you mean what
happened even within that movie it's
heartbreaking no I agree because he had
a little bit of a conscious and a little
bit of a yeah of a of a heart in that
movie yeah he just yeah and he was just
a pawn of Talented Mr Ripley too
um
wow so yeah oh my gosh that's when we
were like a boogie and Boogie Nights
Boogie Nights yeah oh my gosh Scotty who
knew who knew who knew he could do that
wow because there was a time when we
didn't know that Philip Hoffman was like
going to be a great actor she was just a
guy and send a woman and you're kind of
like yeah that's probably just who that
guy is no you know what I mean he's like
Jazzy or whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's in Boogie Nights one of
those great hugs how sick of a woman is
so good I uh it's Chris Fleming loves
watching Al Pacino in anything and only
the Al Pacino and it's exactly right
it's it's so it's getting to just the
pacinos
just skip she's getting the Heat and Sky
well Scarface it's all pretty yeah but
yeah that's funny because that was my
movie when I watched uh Scent of a Woman
I wrote my dad a letter see talk about
books right let's get back to your book
but like it's always been trying to get
to Waterloo Station yeah trying to put
it on paper so you couldn't change it
but that was just like a love letter to
my dad yeah and and I still stand by a
lot of what I said because when I was a
kid like you know 15 13 Maybe
drive a [__] Winnebago to Staten
Island Park it in Staten Island take the
ferry
I just thought like there was a feeling
that Manhattan was like a special place
for very Savvy people oh yes having
lived there you're like that's not true
uh but no but it was overwhelming on my
first visits yeah and and I'm I'm
actually I should give myself more
credit for this for navigating it and
feeling it at home and absolutely
comfortable there and not and not that
terrified of missing the connection or
the transfer yeah and all that yeah I
know it's a lot because I I do have
friends who said I can't handle it's too
anxiety provoking for me and they and
they have to avoid it and then what you
realize to survive in Manhattan is you
have to carve out your little way yeah
not the whole thing don't do the whole
thing no you're a little way yeah and
that's why again when I say I'm a little
on the Spectrum I don't know if that's
true but like I thrived in that way I
always ate at my moons you know what I
mean oh man that's my pre-show meal yeah
and I always catch this train and go I
need just get in your little ritual was
very comforting that's a
it's true if you look at all of it it's
paralysis but if you're just like that's
why stand up coming into Manhattan and
learning the city I mean talk to any
comic you're like it's over by Broadway
Club it's by God it's by the old Gotham
you know what I mean it's by the old
improv like these are still the
landmarks no because that's where we
went totally riddled with adrenaline so
of course we remember where it is yeah
but it's the adrenaline that's a great
point because
I am driving around the the city going
to different different interviews and
plugs and things and I'm going by the
Laugh Factory and I'm going by the store
and I'm filled with bile really as I
yeah because these were places that shut
me out while I while I lived here and I
couldn't get on and Jamie Masada was
convincing I don't know if you ever
heard about this but his thing was to to
get young comedians to be a character
that had nothing to do with their life
or their biography so he would say okay
buddy you are the garbage man you do
only jokes about garbage and it was this
incredibly cynical calculated idea to
get development deals from the networks
because they were very lucrative in the
90s and up until 2000 and it was just so
Twisted he's trying to hack the system
totally
what did he tell you to do luckily you
are told to me
he said you like kid who never grow up
and so I was like all right that's not
actually true but at least it's a little
bit closer to what I yeah what you're
making me realize when I was in New York
City I'm a little bit silly in a loving
way it was like you should wear long
sleeve T-shirts and like an Atari shirt
over it yeah so you had to have a hook
but here's the thing like look like an
old kid commercial wrong in terms of
Commerce in that TV is a very efficient
look yeah look that way business yeah
it probably held me back that I didn't
look my like my act and at any point
that people are interested yeah when I
saw you I don't remember often what
people are wearing and I'm sure I
mentioned this the other two times but
when you did that set of the comic
connection you were wearing a heart a
red a crimson red Harvard football
sweatshirt yeah I still have that switch
and I was like adorable man I was like
what is this because Again comedy was
like if you need a place to open a beer
you put it on account you pop it like a
golfer and you [__] yeah
unless you're a [__] [__] exactly
and then you come up looking like
Malcolm Gladwell to be honest and
proving that stand up is quite easy
so let's talk a little bit more about
the book your mom didn't like the
greeting card yeah yeah so and she's not
gonna like me talking about her twin
brother who was a burglar and fence the
best word designer Boston accent burglar
yeah he he was a a very interesting very
entertaining man but he was he was a a
derelict and a lunatic and and didn't
bathe and had had
a very interesting story about Uncle
Norman was that he was working at the
post office and it was there was a big
snow bank and it was very snowy and his
job at the post office was he was a
janitor so he did everything involving
that when you were a custodian in the in
the 50s or 60s
yeah yeah not a good accent right but
Uncle Norman was a custodian at the post
office it was a government job and it
had benefits and he was he was shoveling
some snow and a Truck either a Sears
truck or a truck associated with another
deep pocketed Corporation backed into
Uncle Norman and as this was happening
Uncle Norman always told us he said and
I knew at that moment my time had
arrived and and he was that lawsuit with
that lawsuit he bought a house and with
that house it was a duplex so he was
able to rent out the other apartment
space where he's like the guy in the
wheelchair and he's like if you wait
yeah something good is coming down the
line and it's like a huge injury and a
loss yes wow yes and he was just
thrilled and and for the rest of his
life he he dealed in stolen merchandise
and and so we I I don't know if I talked
to him seriously yeah I don't know if I
talked that's the irony I don't know if
I talked about this in the in the book
but we would have great electronics and
we were broke we were on food stamps but
we would have a good TV and a good
stereo throughout the 70s it was never
the same TV never the same stuff because
he would resell things that he had given
us and and like once yeah we would bring
it back and then he would get us another
one and it was either the same better or
worse but Beggars can't be choosers and
then my my Uncle Norman at one point and
it was probably just he was storing it
at my mother's house until the heat was
off we had a pinball machine in our
kitchen and not a plastic one that you
would get at Sea is it was a it was from
an arcade or a sub shop it was a sub
shop pinball machine
kitchen no it was the it was not the
who's Tommy but that's the only one that
people know pinball machines it was a it
was a a stock car racing type thing and
it was an old-fashioned and it didn't
have the digital it was really old but
it was yeah it was really cool man and
at one point my brothers took off the
the glass that covered it so we could
just run up the high scores by flicking
the the things while we were playing
pinball and it was just it was a lot of
fun and it was this weird little Oasis
of utter poverty where we essentially an
arcade and also I had a gumball machine
like from the front of the grocery store
that that Uncle Norman had lifted and so
I I started this candy store in my
garage called gully's gumballs and you
could
111 you could buy a gumball in my garage
and let me tell you something the
gumball was a loss leader for the for
the candy that I bought at a at a candy
store in in Lynn Mass and I would resell
it at a huge mock-up I just wanted to
get you in the door at the yeah
on Amazon they don't make money on the
streets
yeah you're gonna buy a mallow cup or
yeah wow yeah Goldman's
what was it I was a gully's gumballs and
I was an entrepreneur until I was
telling the story of my of my coup I I
thought I'd invented capitalism because
I was telling somebody at a at a at a
Passover seder I said so what I do is I
buy the candy for a nickel and then I
sell it for a dime like I invented some
some brilliant scheme I invent profit I
had invented profit and my own I
invented profit my middle brother and I
don't know if you had this with anybody
in your family their job was to uh
anytime there was a swelling of my
self-esteem they would they would
immediately pop it so I'm telling the
story about my my brilliant scam of
charging more than I paid for candy and
my brother Max said don't be so
obnoxious
and
Pete
I don't I don't know how many times
we've been slapped in the face yeah but
it was it was that but worse it hit me
right in the stomach and it just and it
was in front of people and I was on such
a high and and he was so put off by my
personality that I and and and you're
giving the benefit of the doubt you're
like oh he was probably two or three
years old but like I said he was 19
years old when he just robbed me of of
any kind of of Pride and excitement and
I just remember that was like kind of a
there were a number of things that that
were demarcation points in my childhood
but that one was a a real like holy [__]
I'm not the same as I was before he said
that oh wow
yeah there's a
Jimmy Eat World song that I love at the
middle and it's not the middle oh the
middle is a it's a great song it's a
great song that was my divorce anthem
it'll just take some time yeah it'll get
better everything will be all right yeah
and I was in the car listening to like
Dropkick Murphys and feeling angry and
then [__] Jimmy world comes on so
mixes up the vibe this is Radio Days
yeah right now I get it so I hear
[__] I'm like yeah it's gonna be okay
put it in uh I'm listening to the middle
little Easter egg who cares who [__]
cares but there's a song called like
yeah I know you care we care we're
caring we're creating the caring yeah
but um you made it weird creating the
characters
13. Jesus anyway
um
the chorus of the song is you sucked
that lucky feeling right out of me yeah
and I really relate to that because it's
a fragile thing yeah it's like a little
baby bird so careful with any kind of a
accomplishment so they're they're
publishing a uh an excerpt from the book
in Rolling Stone and oh [__] yeah and I
know if I were to tell my mother or my
brothers or anyone they would say either
oh I don't read that or oh good for you
good for you
and and it'll just take all the
excitement so I don't share anything
with them because they can suck the joy
right their Joy vultures these people
and they just they never match my
enthusiasm for anything who's the
publisher ugh yeah and is there a
publisher I could have mentioned that
she would have known other than random
house or or it's you're just left with
it's not enough yes yeah yeah and it
never it never ends and sadly I still
need to to I wouldn't say impress her
but make her make her proud and the
compliments you get I don't let's go
over these have you ever gotten I don't
know how you remember it all yeah that's
a terrible one it's a terror that's not
a compliment no and if you said that to
them they would accuse you of being
sensitive yeah yeah that's really really
hard I've gotten them look at you and
you Ross
it was at a funeral and my brother was
standing next to you know Patty Ross no
oh she's she's this great comedian and
an actress you'd recognize her because
she's been in a lot of Boston filmed
movies she was in she was in the most
like like not the fighter but she was in
Spotlight she played one of the
secretaries and she's a great article
guys she's got this great voice and she
was she was a stand-up who came out here
and immediately was embraced and and and
and and pushed ahead but she told me
something early on in comedy that was so
great because the audiences could be
just just treacherous in Boston she said
fourth wallum
fourth wallum they put a wall between
you yeah you don't need to acknowledge
these people they're lemmings
they're Lemmings I've heard a different
strategy which is sometimes don't build
a connection like a tube from you to
them put a tube up into the sky like
into a higher power or another meaning
Yeah because sometimes it's not safe it
goes back to Portuguese to the tennis
ball sometimes it's not a safe
connection to establish you find a safe
one it's great to put it into that area
of the audience that's if you can't find
a safe one put it into this guy totally
put it to this guy yeah or talk to Sade
talk talk to a safe person collect the
people like me I'm seeing you your book
is [__] brilliant you know what I'm
saying I don't know I thought you
self-publish it then I then I dig you I
thought you self-published and they
still liked it I was kind of sad when I
saw gully's gumballs publishing made it
I'm like oh he's in the hole on this one
let me ask you this here's the thing I
lied when I told my mother you said
Random House no I said I said McMillan
but it's a it's a it's an imprint of
McMillan flat iron yeah but you wouldn't
know flat iron yeah and I knew all she
asked me for was that so she could brag
to her friends yeah yeah and so I said
MacMillan which isn't a it is it's a
white lie I don't know what I don't
understand what the difference is
publish mine that's Harper one uh
imprint from Harper Collins from Harper
Collins yeah so I'm telling my folks
yeah Harper Collins yeah yeah because
they don't they don't get anything and I
mean I'm I'm a recurring character on
life and Beth with Amy Schumer and I
have not told my mother because she
doesn't understand what Hulu is
[__] so funny it's funny and it's
kind of sad oh it is sad but it was
funny I'm seeing myself yeah yeah yeah
I'm seeing yeah but here's here's this
will drive you crazy but it's fun
watching you get crazy I'm never gonna
forget do you understand how easy this
is for me my dad
my dad always goes on a scale of one to
ten Peter how big of a deal is that
wow
they are trying it but they're also
telling you how big of a deal it is to
them yeah that they they my father was
really good at matching my enthusiasm
for something and the understanding what
level of enthusiasm there should be for
to match my enthusiasm for this and he
teaches you
indirectly subconsciously
how you can get with him and you can get
excited and he'll Match Your Enthusiasm
because he loves seeing me excited and
so that he's passed but there's so many
things where my mother will say oh your
father would be so proud
he's best at the cell he's passing the
cellar he's passed everywhere he got two
recommendations and and the SD saw him
on a Friday night and he wanna
have to after after Davidson did a guest
spot that wasn't easy that wasn't easy
yeah right the waves yeah so my dad
matches Your Enthusiasm matches my
enthusiasm and so and so the the book I
know how excited he would get because he
got excited when I made one out of two
free throws at the at the free throw
line anything I did he was excited by
because he took great joy in me took
great that's what they never tell you
about being a parent is that it is
important as important as getting them
through college to enjoy them yeah can I
tell you okay I think you should read
these books father Greg Boyle okay don't
get sweaty he is a he is a priest no I I
no I know I went to a Jesuit college I
remember yeah and he's a Jesuit yeah
you'll love it no I love them he's
incredible tattoos on the heart the
whole language and um uh I'm blanking on
the other one but just get any of his
books on on audio they're great books
all right so he works with gang members
and he tells a story after story he's
one of my like fathers you know what I
mean like he's a guy that's like just
filled place in my heart and he tells
these stories of like gang members
coming in and being like proud of their
report cards and he's like straight A's
he's like check it out yeah I got
straight A's and he opens it and it's
like c d f a c yeah and he goes you know
his inner monologue he's like oh this
guy doesn't know he doesn't even say
this is what I would say this guy
doesn't know what Straight A's means but
he probably says something more gentle
like a little confusion on what Straight
A's is but he just goes oh son you did
it this is incredible yeah and there's
there's this thing that Richard Rohr
says about our relationship to God that
I think about all the time is that like
we are like children drawing bad crayon
drawings and God puts them on the fridge
oh that word what an image what an
analogy it's great right that's
incredible and that's it that's you know
as we're talking about these human
letdowns it did put me in me a year
learning to find
The Source yeah you know what I mean it
sent me on the journey to go like sure
look we're I think we're looking maybe
in the wrong place people are always
going to be people but you can be the
twinkle in the eye you can look at the
report card and go son you did I'm so
proud of you and I know there's people
out there that people gave Mr Rogers
[__] but it's like it's and Mr Roger
said it's all love or lack of it right
yep so yeah you could go what's this F
you know what I say to that [__] off
totally like pick your moments you know
what I mean Leela does it all the time
she says something wrong or she she's
just completely wrong about something
and I go I didn't know that I didn't
know birds are robots or whatever
whatever I do yes and oh I didn't know
that yeah or you know what I do with
Lilo and not to to my own but like I say
what do you think a lot she goes like we
went on Pirates of the Caribbean and she
goes is that is that pirate real I'm
like what do you think you know what I
mean it's just fun oh man that is I know
you don't want to have kids because uh
you're too old now I'm just kidding
because of you of the Great Depression
we've talked about that before yeah but
I just want to give you love I'm not
judging that I'm saying you are a great
father you have that energy and when you
share this wisdom you're giving it to
people it's beautiful oh that's so nice
to hear I I appreciate that but I are
going through some steps involving oh
really yeah oh I'm sorry here I'm
holding you to a standard and then you
said 10 years ago yeah and that's
forgive me that's not a euphemism for
having sex taking steps too do you want
to take some steps tonight no they're
you know eating oysters
there are things because with regards to
pregnancy she's 37 yeah and so we're
going to be 37 and you've got to watch
Adam ruins everything okay there's an
atom ruins everything about pregnancy
okay must watch okay because the risk
for like that guy he's incredible sharp
man the risk uh so when people say that
your risk doubles at a certain age or
something going Goofy uh goofy it goes
from something like 0.01 to 0.02 okay
you know what I'm saying yeah so you
need to watch it it'll make you feel oh
that's interesting better it made us
feel better about breasts
anyone I talk to going into this you
have to watch the Adam ruins everything
on pregnancy okay cool it's incredible
so you're thinking about it yeah oh yeah
you're sniffing around you're going
we're taking steps man well buddy I
already said but I'm like you are a dad
you're a dad thanks man very dead thanks
yeah yeah that's really great to hear I
feel like such a I feel like an old guy
in your temple being like it's a mitzvah
[Laughter]
that's how I feel
hope it happens I hope that turns out
beautiful
Goodwill Hunting
well I just got sidetracked I was gonna
say what do you what do you make of this
when you said I still want my family to
understand see compliment whatever yeah
even though you know intellectually and
you kind of work hard on yourself you're
like I still go back and I still go yeah
I have to and I need that you said
something the last time either on stage
or backstage at Lago where you were
saying no it was backstage in your
dressing room where you said I don't
your father just showed up and you said
I don't let them come to my shows and I
don't invite them and I remember
thinking to myself and not as a bit I
just remember thinking to myself you can
do that I thought you had to allow these
toxic people into your into your show
because they they spent a lot of money
to get you through school school and
everything like that but but it's it's
such a healthy thing and this time
around because of that I I felt like
well my mom is a big star of the book
I'm I'm going to have her come and I'll
pay for her to be driven into Boston and
and she'll
say the same thing she says after every
show which is how do you remember it all
yeah which is did I tell you the story
my dad came even though I told him not
to come right to the Wilbur right to the
Wilbur and I told a story that involved
I still tell this story actually I'm
still doing it involved him not knowing
he had pushed the wrong button on his
phone and I you know Standing Ovation
thousand whatever people Wilbur big deal
homecoming always special special and my
dad again I I want to buffer this with
like everyone's doing the best they can
I get it but he the comment that he said
was that didn't happen that was what he
said he goes that never happened the
story oh wow and I'm like the point of
the story was that you didn't know it
was happening like that's the that's the
mechanism of the story was that you were
in the dark so and then I don't know if
your family is like this then the next
day I'm talking to my mom and my she'll
be like your father loved it and like
I'm like it's interesting they fact
check my my set and and question whether
I do here's the question really happened
and they don't understand the idea of
emotional truth and and that
exaggeration doesn't negate yeah yeah
yeah that's interesting and it's just
well let me ask this is what I was going
to ask you mind blowing but but I I just
remember thinking that I do not have to
have these people at my show and if they
want to come this was the thing in that
little
um allowance I made I said if they
really want to come they'll get tickets
themselves and show up instead of
expecting me to arrange it and tell them
that the times and it's just and and so
that assures that they won't come that's
how I feel when my mom were like my
friend uh Johnny B A Johnny wants to
come yeah right right um the link is
yeah yeah because he's not coming
totally but my mother he was being nice
to you he was going like I want to see
that you said something a moment ago
where you said that doing the best they
can and here's my question
um are they going to therapy once a week
are they inviting you to be in their
therapy are they reading books on what
it means to be the uh grandparent or an
adult and things are they really doing
their doing their best and and what's
the reality Peter here's here's my could
be just defensive response meaning I had
to build this yeah yeah maybe it's not
real maybe I should just say you're
[__] right
I always say if I was let my dad my mom
anybody if I was them I'd be that
meaning to you and I it's an option to
go I could go to therapy if I were them
if I had their past if I had their
biology their physiology every every
experience they've ever had every guy at
the [__] Paddock smoking a cigarette
going you go to [__] therapy Jay you
might as well chop off your [__]
balls kid that is in there in like the
key years yeah the brain is being formed
and that got kneaded into the dough yeah
if I was him I'd be him if I was her I'd
be her and there is a surrender to that
and you know Rayne Wilson did the same
thing he was like are they really doing
the best thing you know why I know it's
the best they're doing it's what they're
doing
the end it's what it's reality we can
argue with it but we'll only be wrong
every single time
Byron Katie we go out of our way to
improve ourselves in so many different
ways and
for instance
if you're a doctor you have to keep up
with the information yeah right and you
you sometimes have to be recertified and
all these things and if your father was
a doctor and was practicing he would
keep doing that and yet he was a parent
and he's not doing any of the things to
become a better parent and and everybody
in my life would say they did their best
and it included not trying to get better
at any aspect of what I expected from
that I hear that but as someone who's
experienced depression and anxiety yeah
we only call it depression because we
always got to work in the special the
great to Fresh on Max yeah it's not
streaming on Max yeah uh I say that like
that's a hot take no it's called Max one
of my [__] a hack anyway
I just look this is just dabbling in
compassion because I love anger yeah
[__] love it yeah I know what it's
like to just not be able to for example
on a certain day exercise even though I
know right it'll extend my life and help
my mood and turn it around and some days
I just go eat [__] I go in and I ask the
boardroom of my psyche
hi I'm higher functioning Pete I'm the
high I'm I'm the CEO here they all laugh
they'll laugh that I think I'm the CEO
and I go I'd like to exercise today
because I think we're getting in a rut
yeah and they all vote and I'm out voted
I can't do it it's just a colorful way
okay yeah I think and you do this seven
days a week
exercise or try to exercise no have this
have this vote this is voted down seven
days a week what I'm saying is that your
parents are voting it down seven days a
week 365 days a year and however many
years and and here's the here's the
thing that I finally got into after all
these years close to just accepting that
but also realizing that well if they're
not going to put any effort I'm not
going home as much as I used to and if
they invite me out on these things into
these things and I've done it with
friends and I've done it with the family
I don't have time for this because there
are people who I go over to Pete
Holmes's house and if I were to tell
Pete Holmes that he made me really
uncomfortable the last time because he
didn't yeah because he's short shifted
or yeah or dismissed this Pete Holmes
would feel bad about it not become
defensive not put it on me not give me
an example of how I did something
similar to him he would feel kind of bad
and and so I I I don't have to I don't
have to dismiss them entirely and and
not have a place for them in my heart
but I don't have a lot of time for them
anymore yeah I hear that man I hear that
I understand yeah
I had a joke I'm on the back nine
of Life yeah I [__]
Bill Burr at The Comedy Store the other
night was like if you're having fake
arguments with people in your mind just
get that person away and I was like you
know I bristled against that I was like
I don't know if I can know Dan Soder
calls them shower arguments or things or
shower fights we're in the shower but
you just mentioned something truly
powerful which is I've been doing it on
stage and I just decided I'm not gonna
do it on stage it's it's just not the
funny to like
real ratio is a little bit off but I was
like every time this is just true in my
family
it's just a thing an extended fan it's
like a Boston thing
if I look for an apology it almost
always ends it no it always ends with me
apologizing for having my feelings hurt
oh wow so why would you abandon
something that's that real and you think
and yeah because eventually you're going
to get it right as as I come up on 30
years of Comedy there are things
from 30 years ago in my notebook that I
stuck with because they were original
and also said something about me
you should not yeah and I saw people
nodding and I was like you know what
I'll take nods yeah because those people
less alone eventually you're going to
get lash and you're going to find
something and maybe it'll just be a
sentence amongst a bigger thing but you
get that sentence and that and that will
that will resonate man because that
happens to me all the time where I stood
up for myself on that instance when my
mother said I looked evil yeah and the
next thing I know I'm looking over at
her and she's she's whimpering because
she feels attacked and that's what Sade
she said she didn't hear anything she
you said all she heard was criticism
criticism criticism criticism criticism
criticism right and and it was and so I
I I I lost that's an interesting thing
again Val's strategy is so when I said
in this dust up with my dad I apologize
to him and then I said would you
apologize does to me because my feelings
were hurt and he he wouldn't and but it
was like I was joking and I really
believe he believes that and then he
goes but then he did say I'm your father
Peter I would never want to hurt you so
then I tell Val that story and she goes
I think that is the apology you're
waiting for yeah my mother's version I'm
sorry but but this is actually I'm
trying to defend my dad and saying he
did sort of say it they'll just so I did
something called the work I go for me to
be safe this is Byron Katie I go for me
this is the belief that I caught myself
feeling for me to be safe I need my
father or my mother to understand and
see me in a way that I understand being
understood and seen like is that true
it's absolutely not true I'm waiting for
I'm waiting for someone like you to come
in and be like
I wow of course
yes I'm sorry are you crazy I I didn't
know you felt that way I'm humiliated
like that's not happening right right
but you have to sometimes Val goes wait
run the tape back and we rewind it and
goes he said I'm your father I would
never want to hurt you I would prefer I
mean father I'm sorry I did hurt you yes
but he's saying my intention wasn't to
hurt you that's as close as we got and
we go you know what
bingo
Yeah question mark Bingo questions this
is how you play family bingo bingo the
car it's all just like satanic symbols
yeah Bingo yeah oh my gosh my mother's
equivalent of what your father said was
what do you think I wake up in the
morning and think how can I hurt my son
I'm telling you buddy there is a fog
over the entire Northeast yeah it's like
Chemtrails yeah dude
everybody's going well
Sam
yeah
there's and there's nothing in between
that yeah yeah either you're waking up
in the morning looking at how to hurt
Gary or you're completely innocent and
immediately forgivable you're right and
you should not even bring it up
yeah
the part of the joke I'm not a Hitler
I've apolog that's so funny
I've apologized to Leela because she was
choking me she was on my back and she
she just under doesn't understand next
very well and she's choked me couldn't
breathe and my baby you're choking me
and and she didn't like that I
no butted her right you know we're
playing and she's feeling all those
things she's feeling embarrassed yeah
she stopped the fun she she hurt me who
knows what she's feeling but she she
like kind of cowers all I said was baby
you're choking me yeah and I was like
sweetheart I'm so sorry yeah you're good
is what I say to Leela a thousand times
ago you're good you're safe you're loved
I just right that's what we need dude
and I say it to Leela so much the last
time I said Gary you're good you're safe
you're loved I mean that I'm dead
serious and I say to Leela so much one
time I said and she goes you say that
all the time stop saying that and I was
like oh I [__] love it I love it I
want you to be embarrassed that I love
you so much that I look at the report
card those Straight A's yeah
oh my gosh yeah it reminds me of that
moment in
remember the original Parenthood with
Steve Martin the film when his son is at
the top of Clock Tower gunning down
strangers with a rifle and he says
that's my son he's such a great shot
I don't remember that is that
extraordinary he's such a great shot
because he was
wow
yeah I mean it's one of those things
that in a different Universe where I got
to that idea first and I'm not sure I
would oh would I be pleased with that
one that is so well that's God putting
the
the pictures on the fridge yeah let's we
don't have to unpack all that back right
I understand yeah it's unconditional
Love's a real tricky one here's a bit
I'm working on I go I think God loves
you just the way you are and God loves
me just the way I am isn't that annoying
does that suck totally of course because
you worked really hard yeah to get this
love and it was going to come no matter
what you did yeah I say it was so much
more exciting when I thought God was
like the Jason Bourne guys in the room
with all the computers going like he
masturbated again deployed a boy
that was such a rush to win over the
Angry Dad God yeah and Penance and yeah
and be sweet and help people just so I
can get back on his good side I was like
but that's a that's a toxic that's my
oldest brother's biggest complaint about
my dad is that my dad was so impressed
with everything we did he said it didn't
give him a realistic view of how the
world was going to interpret me and and
I think now you miss you're Miss reading
it the world was going to be that way it
was he was telling you that there was
somebody who was always going to see you
yeah in the best light that's what we're
not for yeah by the way I pick Leela up
you're gonna say I pick Leela up from
preschool it's like [__] Shawshank oh
yeah kids are screaming and walking's on
wet why is this kid wet he's head to toe
so that's so funny you know the kid
cutting an apple with a knife like what
is this how old is she now four she's
gonna be five in like 11 days so so
my thing is
she's getting the full Buffet I know
some of these kids they're wild in your
book you use Duds I love calling some of
the kids does of course they're not duds
I'm just joking but it's like no no some
of these kids are like as a kid I was
very critical of the kids of of my age
it was just so cruel in my head though
but it's in my ACT I'm out here judging
I judge my daughter's friends I'm out
here judging that nobody gets a pass
which is a reflexive thing yeah did you
ever
did you get to the part where I went to
Hebrew school for the first time no I'm
an anti-semite so I skipped down oh no I
get that but but I did the same thing
the first time I read a Prayer for Owen
meanie anything to do with Christianity
that's not for me no I'm kidding
wonderful I'm kidding you are the king
of yes overwhelmed by the prayer for own
meaning Christianity because I was like
Wow there is so much more I knew I knew
Catholic and I knew Protestant yeah and
there was there were different sectors
of protestantism within that and then
when I got to college I realized there
were like 90 different Southern Baptists
and and we're like uh distilleries you
know what I mean like whiskey yeah we're
a mash whiskey wow you're a southern man
yeah yeah and and so my mother drives me
to my first day of Hebrew school and the
thing about Hebrew school is that it
comes right after regular school so
these kids who have been cooped up all
day get a brief success between regular
school and Hebrew school and so they're
outside of the synagogue and they're
running around and they're behaving like
kids do during recess and that they're
screaming and laughing and and jumping
and running and I'm a little bit
overwhelmed because I'm like I don't
know any of these kids and they're all
having fun and they seem to know each
other and my mother looks at them and
obviously doesn't remember ever having
been in recess as a kid because she was
about 50 at the time and she said and
I'll never forget this as long as I
lived I knew as I don't know how often
this happened to you growing up but you
knew you knew that bookkeeper I'll never
forget this yeah and I didn't know why
but I knew this is something she looked
at all the little Jewish kids and they
were eight or nine and she said and and
with disdain in her voice I didn't have
the word disdain but I knew that she was
revolted by these people and she said
look at the Jews they're Wild
oh my God you've taken my breath away
many times during this chat and it's
never I don't know the word
self-hating Jew I didn't yeah but I I
was like oh she's put off by just the
wow and also she was telling me you're
not to behave like that yeah you will be
wow yeah that was ugly that's rough man
yeah I always
yeah
a lot that brought up a lot
but that exact same thing was happening
in the various versions of that within
every religion yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah no it's true the you're not
gonna be like that was such a huge
energy for me in fact I've said this
before my Jewish friends tended to be a
lot more
um not always I'm just talking about my
Jewish friends we're closer with their
buddy parents how interesting I've told
the story before but I was at a dinner
me my brother no I found that too and
the and the Jewish parents other than my
own parents were pretty close with their
kids friends yeah yeah yeah there was
just a different style yeah and this kid
put his dad in a headlock lovingly
jokingly they were playing yeah and gave
him a noogie the dad's dying laughing
it's just like a silly funny moment my
brother and I both remember that my dad
just looked at us like he gave us like
don't don't you dare
I've tried to do this as a bit I haven't
tried it yet my father would say I'd
never allow it yeah yeah
and my compassion is I'm like they grew
up in a Time totally yeah they had to go
and get it but they couldn't they
couldn't full disclosure I'd do a joke
about this different time so full
disclosure but I always ask when people
say about because my father was from
that different time he was a World War
II vet and greatest Generation but he
never said anything sexist racist
homophobic or or or
um denigrating any any culture and so I
always say this a different time this
was before the famous Schism between
right and wrong when they split over
creative differences
um Abraham Lincoln your father was older
than Abraham Lincoln because he saw
through that that nonsense yeah it's
just a different a different time it
doesn't during each of these different
times there were groups of people
millions of them doing the opposite
thing the thing that could have gotten
them killed hiding Jews during the
Holocaust us helping black people escape
the southern slave owners and and I'm
sure there were witches being burned at
the stake and there was a counter
protest to that yeah yeah well there
probably were people yeah with pails of
water
hiding those hiding those Sorcerers I'm
very Progressive but I do think they
were Rich yeah
yeah John Proctors
ah don't get me started on Salem Salem
town which is now Danvers that's a fun
one
interesting you got a that's a Goldman
you gotta have that nothing of
historical import happened in Salem it
all happened in Danvers yeah all of it
and what is now Peabody is it now baby
yeah John Proctor the the male this was
Chris Fleming did this great joke that I
forget who I think it was Josh conleman
so Chris Fleming says that he and Josh
gone with me you know Josh right he and
Josh goneman moved out of Boston and he
said and people say well why did you
guys leave Boston so quickly and he said
uh do you remember how during the the
witch hysteria there were for some
reason men accused of witchcraft
[Music]
that's what he said and that's why we
left Boston so quickly oh
Giles Corey yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then and John Proctor who
is who is uh buried
in a
an extension of the Route 128 area is
John Proctor's grave and so you can you
can like walk to the Barnes Noble and
just walk by his his grave and he was a
accused of being away yeah oh yeah
yeah well was anybody that made a
contract with the Devil
or had more than two cats I heard no or
was a landowning woman you know
basically right a single landowner oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's all it was
the same stuff yeah anyway let's end on
a lighter note okay it could be in the
book it doesn't have to be
uh can you tell me a time in your life
you've had to answer this a couple times
that you laughed really really really
really really really hard maybe to the
point of Tears maybe you're falling over
maybe somebody farted maybe somebody
fell
maybe you're in church or uh Temple or
something where you're not supposed to
laugh
uh anything come to mind
oh my gosh I had this friend named
Billy mommy and mommy in yeah he's now
known as will Marmion but back then he
was Billy mamian or my mother still
calls him Billy mamia
no New England parents could ever get
their kids friends names right but they
would just whatever was closest to a
name they grew up with that became the
name of the of the of the kid and this
is off the Dome don't think I prepared
this this bit but it sounds like a bit
right sounds like yeah anyhow Billy
Mommy and was the funniest kid I knew
and I knew I knew Gary Goldman
and and it's very close yeah yeah I was
I was Gary Goldman at the time and and
Billy mamian and I were sitting outside
the Warren Five Cent Savings Bank and I
I put the story in the in the book this
is a little tease I guess and he said my
mother was in the Warren five cents baby
as a savings bank for so long one thing
he said that I thought was just really
smart but also funny he said
they only allow you to deposit five
cents in there and somebody in there
must have a quota and so that's what's
taking so long because they have to make
change for the quarter because you're
only allowed to bring in five cents to
this bank and then okay so then so
that's a brilliant joke
then a woman walks by and I just want to
this is the the beauty of the child mind
right that it goes from high status to
low status and everything in between in
terms of Comedy so there's [__] jokes
there's fart jokes and then there's
something as sharp as the five cent
thing and he also said that the name of
the bank owner was it was the Warren
Five Cents Bank he said the the bank
owner was called Warren the Warren they
had to call Warren to see if it was okay
I mean this is just a a genius comedic
mind he's a lawyer now which makes sense
because he's really sharp right so
anyhow he uh then pivots to this a woman
walks by with just a run-of-the-mill
mangy looking uh ski hat because it was
really cold out and he uh rolled down
the window and he said nice hat lady did
your dog make it
and I I immediately pictured a dog
knitting with glasses and also a knit
cap on the dog because they had knit
that before and the knitting with
glasses and it was a dog and and as much
as I love the five cents because I love
a good sharply worded joke that dog
image then I was crying did your dog
make it he was like he went from from
Steven Wright to insult comic like like
that and it made to this day I I mean oh
my word
dog make it did your dog make it
it was it was also a little bit of a Far
Side Right a Gary Larson type thing with
dogs knit it just it had everything it
had everything a dog a dog being crafty
ship it arts and crafts
ship it which we called going back to
your point farts and craps because wow
no no respect for the Arts oh that drove
me nuts that they thought they were so
smart by calling the Arts and Crafts at
Camp Fox and craps
you're also the only person I've been
obsessed with uh thank you for coming to
our UL notice there's no pee in it
because that was like
oh a joke yes you know what I mean a
really strong Joe this one I had I had a
bit about this it is a strong joke
did I ever see this one I don't swim in
your toilet so please don't pee in my
pool you ever see that one in my Open
Mic days I go I love that one you want
to swim in my toilet
here's the here's the uh under the the
the unsaid
idea that makes the deconstruction of
that so good which is that it's only my
decency ethics and integrity that keeps
me from swimming in your toilet I want
to a lot of people I'm swimming in you
whether you know it or not there's a lot
of people swimming in your toilet but I
got I was raised right I'm not sleeping
in your toilet so return the favor yeah
return the favor by not peeing in my
pool I'm not here they are equivalents
that is fantastic oh man that's so good
all right buddy the book is called
Misfit it's a misfit colon growing up
awkward in the 80s and it's an oral
history of the Misfits
um would you Gary your third effortless
return episode would you say keep it
crispy kid
oh thank you oh my what a joy I've been
looking forward to this for for since we
put it on the we put it in I can't tell
you last night because I was like what
if he doesn't want to do are you [__]
kidding I thought maybe you were like
this is warm on it no this is espresso
this is re-energizing yeah keep it
crispy y'all
[Music]